hey jay hey lula how are you what's up
morgan how you doing
good so i just interviewed nathan
fillion and i was asking him
if there was a suicide squad buddy cop
film who would he love to team up with
who do you think
tdk would do so well with flula he said
javelin what do you think about that uh
well i would say
nathan's mistaken the answer is weasel
because this gives nathan all the punch
lines and all the setups and all the
jokes
weasel will just be munching on some
fancy feast that was
laid out on the floor so nathan sorry
the answer is weasel i apologize i've
removed myself from consideration
from this midnight what's it called
midnight run slash last boy scout film
hello
that's an awesome answer jai who would
you love to see boomerang teaming up
with in a suicide squad buddy cop film
uh i'd take black god
um yeah that'd be easy because he's
pretty funny
but um he's also pretty foolish and that
would make me look like an absolute stud
you agree oh a hundred percent look i
mean the problem is that film would only
be one minute long
because black out like hey should i
touch this electric wire
and he doesn't then the creative credits
so then it would all be boomerang i get
it i see i see the genius in this case
uh what about you two together what
about these two characters do you think
it would
you guys would last longer than a few
minutes yeah we'd be we'd do great
yes this is we would do this is like
harry potter
hobbit situation if it's javelin and
boomerang this goes 12 hours short in 60
60 frames per second yeah this goes for
years
and this is the cheapest flula's got the
jokes
and um i've got the uh what would you
say i have flula
the pokes the popes
all right so the entire team was all
together
who do you think king shark would eat
first lula
oh me no yes
look trevlin is delicious he is sexy he
is
he wants to hook up with everyone and
everything i would flirt with king shark
not realizing he's literally eating me
like a queen bee and i would love it
that's awesome i don't know how you're
gonna top that one john what do you
think who do you think he'd eat first
um i think
i think he probably a drip flag
okay surprise why by the way oh i don't
even want a reason i just want rick's
lag
just leave it there i don't i just don't
feel like rick flags gonna get enough
mentions and i think since we're like
saying that
you know we're talking about who's
getting eaten i mean i find joel kinaman
pretty delicious
i would agree and and just wrapping
things up you know obviously john you're
part of the first suicide squad but when
you're reading this script did you have
a few moments where you're like
how are they gonna make this movie it's
so wild
um well i think in the hands of james
gunn you
just have uh supreme confidence that
they will and
i mean that's the thing about him that's
so that's so special to work with
it doesn't even feel like i mean it is
totally bonkers but he's
strangely in control of all of that you
know in a really kind of
it's such a good time making these
movies and i think when when things are
of this size and scale it it it it can
be a pretty stressful environment times
it can feel like we really have to we're
striving to deliver
something that will you know hopefully
work and
it just doesn't feel like that with
james it um
i don't know it feels like there's room
to play on top of all of it which is
um i don't know such a gift yeah so they
see you agreeing
oh nodding heavily if i could nod any
harder it would look
confusing and like i have a head injury
i agree with dry everything all the
words
amazing well i had such a fun time
watching this congratulations on the
film you guys you guys are amazing make
me laugh
thanks logan thanks bye